what do you think if I may ask
uh of somebody like iron Rand and her
philosophy of objectivism so we're the
core principles that reality exists
independently of Consciousness and that
human beings have direct contact with
reality through sense perception so they
have that you do have that ability to
know reality there's two things knowing
that there's an independent reality is
not knowing in that independent reality
those are not the same thing yeah but I
think objectivism would probably
say that our human reason is able to
have contact with that then I would
respond and say
you have to I believe in fact ultimately
in a Conformity theory of knowing that
what that the deepest kind of knowing is
when
there's a a contact a Conformity between
the mind with the embodied mind and
reality but and here's where I guess I
push back on on Rand I would say you
have to acknowledge personal knowledge
as real knowledge because if you don't
you're going to fall preyed amino's
paradox
amino's Paradox is you know this is in
Plato right
to no P well
if I don't know P I'm going to go
looking for it but if I don't know P how
could I possibly recognize it when I
found it
I have no way of recognizing it I know I
have no way of knowing that I've found
it
so I must know P but if I know P then I
don't need to learn about it I don't
need to go searching
so learning doesn't exist knowledge is
impossible
the way you break out of that Paradox is
saying no no no it is partial it is
possible to partially know something I
can know it enough that it will guide me
to recognizing it but that's not the
same as having a complete grasp of it
because I still have to search and find
what I don't yet possess in my knowledge
if we so yeah partial knowledge has to
be real knowledge right personal
knowledge is still knowledge yes